now that the time masters are gone  history has been left unguarded  everything that has happened or will  happen is subject to the exploitation of  time criminals which is why history  needs new protectors it needs legends  my name is Rex Tyler I'm a member of the  Justice Society of America  dad will past the point of worrying  about the timeline  I need to talk to you about the legends  I think they're all in trouble  somebody just blew up New York during  World War two think we can all guess who  that someone is  Nazis hate Nazis it's not like the time  masters are here to stop it we are  history's last line of defense  relax captain we got this  I'm waiting a long time for this a long  time for what to kill you  are you uh sure you know how to fly this  thing let's find out then then meeting  lots of care about business  you